у своїй книзі берлінський журналіст and
smiling ви знаєте на та сприйнятий а
україни до вів плювала картера ганського
союзу з змінилося а у брізні 2014
усміхнений виріс в до криму висвітлю ось
та незаконне проведення референдуму
7 монограми сунутися до пологів кремики
був українським хулі тут і прибув став
російським кулаєва завищення та година
роботи на тканинну
журналісту про dogs 2 місяців проїхав
всю ідею україну you with карпат до
донбас це криму в лобі герою його
книги на кулі так це вся кава а вибач
людою тазіїв ні влада не історії
євро та кримські татари націоналіст це
комуністи різьбленому а ні ні жити і ваш
лихих тисне на мене святої справи серце
малюків у дні та князі
а ось на екрані не бачили ми вирішуємо було
нікого не здаєте індивідуальною стала не
людей дура галльського гаму нового
любеку загадувати про нього skype лом на
частини шастають жертвами російської
пропаганди тисяч залишилося в Україні
пов'язана нас видно на steam та у
менталітеті людей а з сонячних play
вам прагнемо в лику сусід ви до
лихвареві владних інтересах і нате
кого в людей 1 на 1 м какал самості
honor з маком автор за словом і єнса
мелінгу
українці мою з відома тисячу ризницю
квітів рядах не поділяючи народ на
пакеті багатство україни якесь право
знаходжу вирощував що правда поки що в Україні
трава і вина подру животи шляхом саме
на ваше тіло she's mine ліфт авантюрний
нас три я чоловіка я вийду собі подорож до
України
це дуже далеко і душі у кожного дата ваш
там не над забезпечиш на перспективі я
обожнюю ще україну погляду на її історію
там менталітет та її мешканців
на лижі до Європи я одягаюся ще він
не зможе здала ти корупцію щось побуду
вата для себе видно мої будні
sins
за роз'єм smiling подружуся і свою книгу
різьбленими місцями та ними чини
кажи що судячий тракт і публікою по
раку на всі німці ці вкрадені типу
цікавий менталітет нулін утеплений
фасад гарчання русі в україні не булавина